our final suspect smashmouth yes the
nineties alternative rock was
responsible for a musical genre we now
refer to as shrek core been a constant
target since our show's inception now we
are not 100% sure of Smash Mouth
technology hey now this is me mr. Steve
Harwell lead singer of the
multi-platinum grammy-nominated band
Smash Mouth I just heard that somebody
was talking about my band and his
name is Chris Hardwick
aka dollar store Ryan Seacrest
that's not cool brother okay we got to
stop that kind of stuff we may not be
for everyone and I admit that but we
make perfect music for many situations
like a super chill divorce hearing a
raging Bat Mitzvah or a beautiful chili
cheese orgy with Guy Fieri one of my
great friends now I'm not saying I
hacked into your guys's computer using
high-tech powered flip-flops and hair
product but if I did listen up all you
comedians out there I command you tweet
a nice thing about my band right now and
if you don't I'm gonna tell you one last
thing
there's an out Joe
that was very serious we got to give it
to him we got to have a huge amber C bar
well for
I give him points maybe I got smashmouth
on my iPhone sometimes you guys